Một tháng tư các khu tấn công bằng Huawei tiếp tục về thung vong tại gặng nhà buộc greg nát,
tay thành phố Tăng Garok, Tình Rốt sốt của Ngà, Thông Dốc Yulis Luia Sa Chò biết,
in nhất một người trên mạng bốn nửi thương trong độ có bát cho hợp Newgate,
nhiều cơ sở thương mại và một con hàng bị thứ 2 và trái nổ.
Bốn có phòng ngà của Ngài Thung báo đã đến trận tảm lắm Huawei trên lãi thuộc nước này,
trong buộc cạnh các khu tấn công ra tăng.
Ở trường người lại, buộc greg nát cho biết một Huawei tấn công khu trở tại Nhi Cô Pôn,
khiến năm 18 và 14 người bí thương, nhiều cố cạnh như khu a cô,
xù mi và đi đi pro bát chốt cũng vì nhận thung vong.
Không còn u cua nà nổi, hai trong sống người trên 2 trong 3 xo Huawei đã bị đánh trạm trong đêm.
Cung thư điểm, các là đà công bố, và bên trợ nằm mới mốt chiệu lúc là cả nơi ra chỗ cua nà,
trong khi kia cho biết đã sử dụng tới chiếm mi sấu thần trăm cuối sửp con ngon xa,
nằm hành hình xấu, phần nãy át được tài chính ngày càng lớn gió xung độc kéo dài.